[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24
soy herminia fernández comenzamos
alemania tiene una de las tasas de
feminicidios más altas de europa según
estadísticas de la policía federal
criminal
139 mujeres asesinadas es el balance de
la violencia intrafamiliar en el año
2020 por sexto año consecutivo el número
de agresiones cometidas por el cónyuge o
ex cónyuge de una mujer se incrementó
casi en un 5 por ciento en alemania y la
pandemia agravó la situación los grupos
de apoyo a las víctimas de violencia
doméstica han emprendido un trabajo
incansable los activistas condenan el
hecho de que la policía no haya tomado
con suficiente seriedad los casos de
mujeres y que además haya deficiencias
legales de la ley alemana es por ello
que exigen más capacitación para
policías y jueces desarrollar campañas
contra la violencia y aumentar la
cantidad de refugios para las mujeres a
continuación el informe de nuestros
corresponsales en berlín
[Música]
la cara oculta de la violencia lo que
ocurre detrás de la puerta de los
hogares es un gran desconocido durante
mucho tiempo pensé que era la única
víctima de este tipo de violencia y
luego cuando se dio a conocer muchas
mujeres vinieron a decirme yo también
soy víctima de la violencia
intrafamiliar y yo vivo en un pequeño
pueblo así que imagino tener grandes
ciudades sobre todo en estos momentos
con la pandemia del coco
es ven ya ve que tardó varios años en
reconstruirse y encontrar el valor para
hablar
hablar de la violencia intrafamiliar que
casi le costó la vida en dos ocasiones
en su casa no lejos de darmstadt en el
oeste de alemania- svenja ve que llevaba
el diario en el que relataba esta
relación tóxica y violenta
está todo escrito desde el primer gol yo
presenté una denuncia por todo lo que
hizo
esto es lo que escribió una mañana de
abril de 2016
no puedo creer lo que me hiciste todavía
estoy un shock no puedo creer que pueda
ser tan violento casi me quitas la vida
lo siento
tener un hijo con este hombre que más
tarde será condenado a un año y medio de
prisión con suspensión condicional por
agresión una nimiedad comparada con las
palizas que sufrió durante años y por lo
que ella describe como un intento de
feminicidio pollice extendido en fall
out cuando la mujer policía que me
recibió cometió un error
presentó una denuncia contra él por
lesiones graves cuando podría haber
iniciado una investigación por tentativa
de homicidio
lo que no le habría permitido librarse
con una condena suspendida
habría ido a la cárcel
y ahí es donde empieza el agresor se
siente confirmado en sus acciones se
siente fuerte porque se da cuenta que no
le pasa nada grave así que no hay nada
que le impida ir más allá un día al
feminicidio
para ayudar a otras mujeres
sven sabe que creó hace dos años un
grupo de autoayuda para víctimas de la
violencia intrafamiliar que ahora cuenta
con más de seis mil miembros hace unas
semanas se enteró de la muerte de una de
ellas
he recibido una noticia terrible una de
las nuestras ha sido víctima de
feminicidio ha sido asesinada
un intento de homicidio cada día y tres
mujeres mueren cada semana a manos de su
pareja o ex pareja
alemania tiene una de las tasas más
altas de homicidio conyugal en europa
por eso cuando jennifer fue encontrada
muerta en este predio en febrero de 2021
en las afueras de la pequeña ciudad de
beebe saint en pleno confinamiento las
sospechas apuntaron rápidamente a su
marido
aquí está la sentencia jennifer fue
estrangulada
un año antes su marido ya la había
agredido y herido violentamente en su
casa
durante el juicio los celos de la pareja
están en el centro del debate pero tras
una confesión detallada la fiscalía
reclasificó el asesinato que conlleva
una pena de 25 años de prisión en
homicidio no premeditado el veredicto se
pronuncia en noviembre de 2021
por la agresión agravada
el primer delito son cinco años y por el
homicidio son doce años
en total es una condena de 13 años y 6
meses de prisión
fue una sentencia difícil de escuchar
para la familia y su abogado
para él richter conocía a la víctima
desde que era un niño
trece años y medio de prisión significa
que le podrían rebajar la pena después
de cumplir dos tercios de su condena
por lo que sería liberado rápidamente
estaremos en una situación en la que
saldrá de la cárcel cuando los niños
sean todavía menores y qué pasa después
pedirá la custodia de los hijos que le
han quitado la prensa local también hizo
eco del juicio no muy lejos de allí en
darmstadt christine de que les sigue con
atención los informes judiciales dirige
un centro de asesoramiento para mujeres
víctimas de violencia intrafamiliar
cada año el centro acoge a 150 personas
en las familias afectadas por la
violencia intrafamiliar la situación ha
sido particularmente dramática desde el
comienzo de la pandemia porque la vida
cotidiana se concentra entre las cuatro
paredes del hogar tras el juicio contra
el marido de jennifer que también había
pedido ayuda a una asociación está
criticó públicamente el veredicto en un
comunicado según ella cuando un hombre
mata a su pareja suele ser la
culminación de un historial de violencia
que el tribunal no tiene en cuenta
hablamos de asesinato pero alguien que
tiene tal historial de violencia como
puedes decir que actúa por afecto no es
posible sobre todo porque el
estrangulamiento es una forma de matar
que dura mucho tiempo requiere un
esfuerzo físico sostenidos eso es lo que
más nos llamó la atención mientras que
los tribunales españoles y franceses
consideran ahora el asesinato del
cónyuge o de la pareja como una
circunstancia agravante en alemania se
suele considerar como una circunstancia
atenuante esta opinión de 2008 del
tribunal supremo federal sugiere
implícitamente que las víctimas tienen
una parte del responsabilidad
especialmente cuando buscan separarse de
su cónyuge en estas situaciones la
delincuencia puede ser desencadenada y
determinada por un sentimiento de
angustia y desesperación interior en
alemán o jurídico esto significa que si
los sexos fueron causados por la
separación y la víctima quería separarse
entonces esto no puede ser considerado
como un factor agravante la asociación
alemana de abogadas que está haciendo
campaña por una reforma del código penal
considera esta jurisprudencia obsoleta
exigimos que el llamado carácter de
género sea considerado como una
circunstancia agravante de este modo se
sensibilizará a la policía y a la
judicatura sobre la violencia de género
a pesar de la entrada en vigor en
alemania del convenio de estambul contra
la violencia de género hace cuatro años
el parlamento alemán aún no se ha puesto
de acuerdo sobre la definición de
feminicidio
las organizaciones de protección de las
víctimas llevan años denunciando la
falta de recursos y la ausencia de una
estrategia policial por eso el 14 de
febrero cuando otros celebran el día de
san valentín las organizaciones
denuncian esta violencia contra las
mujeres que con demasiada frecuencia se
ignora mucha gente sigue pensando que la
violencia intrafamiliar es un asunto
privado que debe quedarse en casa sigue
siendo un tema tabú y las mujeres
víctimas siguen avergonzando ustedes su
situación al igual que los niños que la
padecen también se avergüenzan de hablar
de ella debemos seguir poniendo el dedo
en la llaga' tenemos que ser conscientes
de esta violencia cuyo verdadero alcance
ni siquiera conocemos y eso empieza por
decir las cosas como son cuando una
mujer muere es un feminicidio y no una
tragedia familiar porque para denunciar
y combatir estos crímenes hay que
nombrarlos por eso cada día estos
jóvenes activistas analizan la prensa
regional y nacional para destacar la
cobertura mediática del feminismo
fue asesinada por su vecino es un caso
para nosotros tomaremos un pantallazo
una simple búsqueda con algunas palabras
clave
buscamos artículos que hagan hincapié en
el motivo de los celos por ejemplo drama
de los celos tragedia de los eps pero
también todos los términos que tratan
los feminicidios como casos aislados
como una tragedia familiar o un drama
familiar
en 2021 el 93% de los 700 artículos
analizados utilizaron estos eufemismos
para referirse al feminicidio
el año pasado sólo encontramos 38
artículos que utilizaban el término
feminicidio para referirse al asesinato
de mujeres y también nos hemos dado
cuenta de que cada vez se habla menos de
los asesinatos de mujeres este término
se utilizó sólo tres veces
en general la violencia contra las
mujeres se banaliza siempre se habla de
ella como un caso aislado pero también
hay un componente racista en la
cobertura de los medios de comunicación
porque cuando se habla de los crímenes
de honor por ejemplo se reconoce el
carácter estructural de esta violencia
contra las mujeres pero sólo cuando se
cometen en una comunidad de ignorantes
no es un problema alemán
en 2019 estas activistas han logrado una
primera victoria la principal agencia de
noticias de alemania se ha comprometido
a dejar de utilizar un lenguaje
inapropiado al informar sobre los
asesinatos pero la concientización
apenas está comenzando las estadísticas
oficiales muestran
139 feminicidios en 2020 pero solo
incluyen los homicidios por parte de los
cónyuges o es cónyuges que han sido
investigados
para muchos activistas estas cifras no
reflejan la realidad del feminicidio en
alemania kristina world lo relata en su
cuenta de instagram en un cementerio
virtual para las víctimas que a menudo
permanecen en el anonimato
y más de lo que la gente no se da cuenta
es que las estadísticas que tenemos
sobre delitos en el ámbito doméstico no
tienen en cuenta los feminicidios
cometidos por los padres sobre sus hijas
a los hermanos sobre sus hermanas por
los hijos sobre sus madres
por los primos o los hombres que lo
planean como los acosadores por ejemplo
todo esto se esconde bajo la alfombra y
por tanto la opinión pública no es
consciente de la dimensión del problema
entonces cómo podemos romper el silencio
que rodea a esta violencia contra las
mujeres en alemania en berlín varias
asociaciones feministas se han unido
para crear una red contra todos los
feminicidios
si te parece bien la manifestación del 8
de marzo pensamos que sería afilar
formar un bloque dedicado a la lucha
contra el feminicida con carteles
claramente identificados
tras dos años de pandemia y un nuevo
aumento de la violencia contra las
mujeres quieren presionar al gobierno y
multiplicar las acciones para recordarle
su responsabilidad y la aplicación del
convenio de estambul
hasta ahora no ha pasado gran cosa nos
han prometido un centro de coordinación
nacional para evaluar toda la violencia
de género
y proponer soluciones para los cupos en
centro de acogida por ejemplo
pero hasta ahora es el centro de
coordinación no existe
más
al cambiar las leyes no será suficiente
para resolver el problema hay una gran
necesidad de concientización tenemos que
hablar y reconocer los problemas a los
que se enfrentan las mujeres cuando
buscan menos vivienda cuando están en
situación de dependencia económica
porque esta precariedad también puede
llevar al feminicidio lo que realmente
necesitamos es un verdadero despertar de
la sociedad
en la actualidad alemania sólo dispone
de 7.000 plazas en centros de acogida
para víctimas de la violencia doméstica
se necesitan 14 mil más aunque el nuevo
gobierno ha prometido poner en marcha
una estrategia nacional contra la
violencia de género el número de
feminicidios sigue aumentando en
alemania en lo que va del 2022 unas 20
mujeres han sido asesinadas
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para ver esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]